en direct avec jacques sapir économiste
bonsoir à tous jacques sapir alors un un
auto satisfaction du président de la
république qui est en campagne ça n'a
échappé à personne on va essayer d
disséquer avec vous tout d'abord sur ce
pouvoir d'achat on a eu l'occasion déjà
d'en parler ensemble
emmanuel macron quelques 70 euros de
plus pour notamment les jeunes les plus
défavorisés un pouvoir d'achat
globalement meilleurs sous son
quinquennat
le vrai du faux plat que sa pire
si vous voulez c'est vrai que nos
mesures ont été prises pas le nier c'est
une évidence mais le problème c'est
qu'il ya énormément de trous dans la
raquette c'est ce qu'on disait déjà
effectivement il ya quelques jours
ensemble et si il ya des jeunes qui
rentrent dans ce dispositif et qui
bénéficie effectivement alors c'est pas
grand chose mais ce n'est pas non plus
complètement négligeable c'est une bonne
chose pour eux qu'ils aient cet argent
est bien par contre ceux qui ne rentrent
pas dans le dispositif et qui sont très
souvent dans des situations tout à fait
similaire est bien une loupe en ses
avantages et c'est bien ça tout le
problème
alors autres au travail fait positif de
son quinquennat toujours selon lui la
croissance 6% les résultats du quoi
qu'il en coûte du plan de relance
européen là encore il y à du vrai mais
avec on le rappelle toujours
le creusement aussi des déficits et de
la dette
oui alors d'abord il faut dire 6% ça
semble très fort mais comme on était
tombé de 8 % voire un petit peu plus
l'année dernière nous ne sommes toujours
pas revenus au niveau du pib de 2010 nas
et c'est ça qui est important si vous
voulez pour l'instant nous sommes en
train de récupérer par rapport à la
chute ce n'est pas une réelle croissance
ça c'est un premier point après il ya un
deuxième point c'est que il ya d'autres
pays vous prenez par exemple
l'angleterre les etats-unis même
l'allemagne qui récupère enfin plus vite
que nous parce que dans le cas des états
unis et de l'allemagne il était tombé
bah que nous effectivement mais donc si
on se compare aux autres pays et bien on
voit peu oui nous avons une récupération
qui est forte mais simplement parce
qu'on était beaucoup tomber et qu'il ya
d'autres pays qui étaient moins tomber
et qui se trouve au dessus
alors autre annonce ajax et pierre
concernant cette fois-ci l'assurance
chômage ce n'est pas une surprise
poursuite de cette réforme vous propose
d'écouter le chef de l'état
pour que le travail permette de vivre
dignement et paie toujours davantage que
l'inactivité
nous conduisons en ce moment même une
indispensable réforme de l'assurance
chômage
depuis un mois les règles ont commencé à
changer pour rendre la reprise du
travail plus attractives dans tous les
cas et à partir du 1er décembre de cette
année une nouvelle étape va s'engager il
faudra avoir travaillé au moins six mois
dans les deux dernières années pour
pouvoir être indemnisé alors
qu'aujourd'hui les droits au chômage
sont ouverts au bout de quatre mois de
travail
jacques sapir s'avancer évidemment que
cette réforme a été très très con battue
et elle passe un petit peu au forceps et
il va changer la vie de nombreux
chômeurs en france oui tout à fait alors
là d'abord à sauver sur ces deux parties
il faut dire deux choses la première
c'est que au niveau des chiffres il se
trompe ce n'est pas trois millions on
vise 3 million deux cent mille chômeurs
que nous avons france c'est 4 millions
de ça parce que tout simplement il
exclut la catégorie b et la catégorie d
et pourtant ce sont très exactement des
chômeurs avec des différences techniques
par rapport à la catégorie à b qui
doivent être montés avec la catégorie ça
c'est un premier point le deuxième point
qui vont retenir c'est qu'il a un
discours si vous voulez de père
fouettard envers les chômeurs comme si
c'étaient eux les responsables de cette
situation alors bien sûr il y à des
postes disponibles c'est une évidence en
réalité il doit y en avoir entre 300 et
400 milles autrement dit c'est à peu
près 10% du nombre
et elle est souvent donc oui c'est très
bien le dire à vous devez occuper ces
postes mais admettons que tous ces
postes se soient remplies il en
resterait encore les neuf dixièmes
autrement dit il en resterait plus de 3
millions 6,3 millions 7 et de ce point
de vue là ce qui me frappe c'est qu'il
ya un discours qui apparaît extrêmement
forts sur ce point même si il faut le
dire tout est déjà dans la loi parce que
toutes les mesures pour pénaliser les
chômeurs qui ne font pas acte y
actifs de recherche d'emploi ça existe
déjà dans la loi bien mais le fait que
le président le réaffirme veut dire vous
les chômeurs vous devez prendre
n'importe quel emploi vous êtes
responsable de votre situation or c'est
une monstruosité de dire ça je viens de
voir quelques personnes qui profitent du
système mais pour l'essentiel ce sont
des gens qui ne trouvent pas d'emploi et
donc il faut quand même leur applique et
disent que c'est le coin le plus
discutable de discours en tout cas et
macro ne s'arrête pas là nous ne devons
pas viser 7 % de chômage dit-il mais
bien le plein emploi c'est c'est
l'ambition entre fx le gouvernement une
possibilité selon vous
le plein emploi il est toujours possible
mais encore faut-il avoir la politique
économique et qui va avec qu'est ce que
ça veut dire le plein emploi ça veut
dire tout d'abord qu'il faut investir
massivement qu'il faut accroître la
consommation et qu'il faut éviter que
cette consommation profite à nos
concurrents et non pas l'industrie
française se sont ça les trois
conditions du plein emploi après si
emmanuel macron nous dit quelles sont
les mesures qui vont aller avec cela
cindy mais voilà la france va rétablir
une certaine manière des droits de
douane ou par exemple en utilisant une
taxe carbone aux frontières à 20% ou 25%
l'équivalent de droits de douane s'il
nous dit la france va sortir de l'euro
et dépressif de 20% là on pourrait rire
oui effectivement il ya une chance que
l'on puisse un jour retrouver le plein
emploi mais
il faut avoir conscience de ce que cela
veut dire le plein emploi s'est passé de
la situation actuelle est d'environ
quatre millions et demi de chômeurs à
une situation you où il y en aurait
entre eux cinq cent mille et un million
c'est ce qu'on appelle de globalement le
chômage frictionnel et de ce point de
vue là rien dans la politique du
gouvernement rien dans la politique
qu'il a annoncées ne prépare ce type de
situation jacques sapir pour pour
terminer un emmanuel macron kino ses
revenus évidemment sur le pouvoir
d'achat avec l'augmentation des prix du
gaz et d'électricité pour améliorer
cette situation il veut garantir
l'indépendance énergétique et rappelle
la neutralité carbone en 2050 en tout
cas cet objectif et pour cela il veut
donc
décarbonés pour sortir de la crise
écoutez nous vivons chaque jour les
conséquences de la situation actuelle le
plein plus cher à la pompe la facture de
gaz et d'électricité qui augmente ce que
nous vivons ces dernières semaines
nécessite des réponses d'urgence c'est
pour cela d'ailleurs que le gouvernement
à bloquer les prix du gaz c'est aussi
pour cela que ceux d'entre vous qui
gagnez moins de 2000 euros nets par mois
et recevoir une indemnité inflation
exceptionnelle de 100 euros mais si nous
voulons payer notre énergie à des tarifs
raisonnables et ne pas dépendre de
l'étranger il nous faut tout à la fois
continuer d' économiser l'énergie et
d'investir dans la production d'énergies
décarbonées sur notre sol jacques sapir
bonne stratégie là de la part du
président macron qui annonce un par
ailleurs dans la continuité de de cette
phrase la création ça il avait déjà dit
dans son plan 2030 la création de deux
nuits de réacteurs nucléaires
oui alors là c'est peut-être le fond les
plus intéressants de la loterie non mais
tu te remarquer que comme à son habitude
à emmanuel macron a fêté en même temps
alors il dit effectivement il faut une
politique d'indépendance énergétique ne
sais pas d'ailleurs sans rappeler le
discours tu avais fait pierre messmer en
1974 quand il est dans la france avait
lancé son grand programme
électronucléaire dit très bien après
midi on va faire des investissements 30
milliards ici à 2030 honnêtement c'est à
peu près 3 milliards par an c'est un
grand show et en plus il annonce une
dizaine de projets sur lesquels ces
investissements seront réparties
autrement dit on n'a pas la force de ce
pas en termes d'ampleur de
l'investissement et j'aurais nécessaires
aux aboutir à l'objectif est par
ailleurs on disperse ses investissements
sur un nombre trop important de projets
et ça c'est un maltraitance est
d'ailleurs un taux unique de villepin
qui tombe exactement dans la même erreur
il avait annoncé une hausse de
compétitivité c'est une bonne idée il
faut la saluer effectivement mais
immédiatement on a derrière l'idée d'un
saupoudrage
électoralistes ou pour certaines et à
faire plaisir à tout le monde qui va
gâcher immédiatement un cette bonne idée
donc yala avait établi lundi par
ailleurs c'est pas 30 milliards qu'il
faudrait d'ici 2030 c'est à peu près une
quarantaine de milliards par an et c'est
ça et on peut les chiffres dont on a
besoin pour que la france vive et
récupère sa souveraineté énergétique et
avance justement vers l'objectif de la
décarbonation des sources d'énergie on
est plutôt de l'ordre de 40 milliards
par an donc on voit on est très en deçà
des besoins de l'économie française avec
le tour on vient de nous tenir
merci beaucoup jacques sapir de nous
avoir apporté votre éclairage sur cette
partie et ce volet économique